in recent weeks on rare occasions away
from his basement bunker very rare the
very weak the very frail the cognitively
struggling joe
vowed to make unity a top priority we
will remind you
i pledge to be a president who seeks not
to divide
but unify that this is part of the
mandate
given to us from the american people
they want us to cooperate
in their interest and that's the choice
i'll make
and now it's time to turn the page as
we've done throughout our history
to unite to heal we've overcome
incredible challenges as a nation
and we've done it before and we will do
it again
we'll do it by coming together by
uniting after years of
pain and loss unity is not some pie in
the sky
dream it's a practical step
to getting things done yeah just compare
two republican senators to nazis in case
you were wondering here's what joe's
unity platform looks like
he first compared trump supporters to
nazis as they said
he announced plans to offer amnesty to
11 million illegal
immigrants and as we speak another
massive
migrant caravan from central america is
headed straight to our borders
i wonder if they're going to wear masks
after his mask mandate
now biden told him don't come yet
because he said the situation at the
border
isn't going to be transformed overnight
biden also promised to cancel
yes energy independence by the way if
you work on the keystone
xl pipeline you have a great high paying
career job
it's probably going away destroying
countless
jobs in the energy sector and of course
now
creating higher oil energy prices and
yes more dependence on nations that hate
our guts
like russia and china and countries in
the middle east
and he vowed to re-enter yes the insane
paris
climate accords china is viewed as a
developing nation we pay
full freight and he's going to provide
student loan debt relief raise the
minimum wage
nancy pelosi wants d.c statehood and yes
covet election laws you know to be
permanently implemented
and unity so far not a part of the plan